and the New York Times is asking a hotly
debated question should you track your
teens location yes the Pew Research
Center found 16% of parents choose to
use cell phone monitoring apps to
monitor their teens locations the
majority of parents do not psychologist
listen to more rights plenty of adults
balk at the idea of remotely following
an adolescence movements while others
question why any loving parent wouldn't
Lisa de Moura CBS News contributor joins
us now good morning
Renee we've heard Gail already way some
of us at the table already track our
kids movements through through their
phones that's me yeah that makes you
actually but mine aren't aren't tinea
teens yet but you raise some really
interesting questions is this damaging
to the relationship or potentially
damaging to a parent's relationship with
their team it can be so we have research
that tells us that if kids feel like
they're in privacy's being invaded it
does harm to the relationship we also
see situations where it becomes a
cat-and-mouse game where kids are
leaving their phones places turning
their phones off putting more energy
into trying to get away from their
parents and trying to keep themselves
safe we also have the problem that the
data is sort of vague I have seen kids
get into trouble for swinging by a band
home to pick up something with a friend
and then they come home and their parent
is really angry and nothing has gone
wrong I also know lots of teenagers who
are doing all the wrong things exactly
where they're supposed to be so it's a
limited source of information and we
have to recognize at least I really do
believe people who have nothing to hide
hide nothing so I'm thinking if is if
there's a choice between privacy and
security I'm always gonna go for
security and I admit I'm a bit nosy too
but mostly at a time it was really it
would really for me be about security
why is that wrong it's not necessarily
wrong I think it has to feel like your
teenager was doing it with you you don't
want it to be something your teenager
feels being done to them but we should
tell them absolutely it should
definitely be aboveboard and then it can
be a partnership you can say look if I'm
not hearing back from you and I'm
worried I'm gonna check where you are if
your friends want to go somewhere you
don't want to go you can tell them I've
said no and that I could find out
the flip of it is and this is a rational
perspective there's a lot of value to
learning to manage on one's own right
and parents who don't track I encourage
them to say look I'm not tracking you
when you're not with me you are in
charge of your safety you can call me if
you need me but I don't want there to be
any ambiguity about who's responsible
one enterprising youth bought a
temporary cellphone so that they
wouldn't have to use their iPhone and be
tracked I think it encourages
independent thought let me ask you this
when do you stop if you are doing it
with your children when then do you
taper off well I think you should sort
of have a planned expiration date I
think there should be some sense that
this is not an open-ended arrangement
and I think you should keep checking in
with your teenager about what it means
how it's being used
I think certainly by 17-18 parents
should be ready to really renegotiate a
lot of parents track their kids who are
at college there's probably good reasons
for this but what at the same time you
think well it's one thing for your
roommate to know you're sleeping over at
your boyfriend's dorm it's another thing
for your dad to know you're doing that
okay you can track me just don't judge
tracking it's like if you pull this
thread it gets to all of the big topics
and parenting teenagers trust safety
independence privacy so these are the
tough negotiations of parenting young
people and what I like about this topic
is that it gets parents and teenagers to
the negotiating table right there's no
right answer there's no one way and
there's no single decision than any
family these are ongoing conversation so
undergoing ongoing negotiations and you
say raising teenagers comes with
guaranteed discomfort yes though true
comes in the territorio - thank you very
much you bet we always like having you
here